There was a margin of less than 1 millimeter of when the surgeon removed my tuber from
the actor Alice muscle. Why do you think she didn't take a deeper margin? She passed away
a month after my surgery, suddenly, unexpectedly. So I can't ask her. Is that a thin margin that's dangerous?
Well, understand she may have thought she took a much bigger margin, but then when that sample is sent to the lab,
they measure that margin and that was measured at 1 millimeter. There's always she can see the margin to be 1 millimeter.
She'd have to, you know, this is not physically able to see that. Also she might have not wanted to damage your pectoralis muscle.
That's muscle muscle anymore because you cut the fibers of the muscle. I mean, you cut the fibers. So you'd have to, you can't stitch up the individual fiber.
You're going to damage the muscle itself. So maybe that's it. Speaking to her passing away suddenly, that's very sad.
I just talked to a doctor friend of mine who just got a job at mail in December.
And he had to, he was forced to get the vaccine in December. He was at another hospital.
And they allowed him. They accepted his religious exemption to not get the vaccine, but that hospital system was bought out.
And he was going to lose his job like a whole bunch of other people and he was off from job at mail, but they made him get the vaccine.
He told me yesterday he was, I have not been the same. I just, but it's just changed my life. 100% 100% that's what he said.
So, right to help him.
So I would say that it was, that was the margin of less than a millimeter was found on the pathology sample.
But to be honest, it's found on the pathology sample. And it's a margin of one millimeter. It's a margin. That's all you need is a margin.
So, you know, you don't need a, you know, I think a margin of one millimeter, which should we take it a margin of a centimeter? That would have been better.
Really? I don't know. I don't think so. I mean, you just take your whole pack muscle and you're not going to get any cancer there.
It's, it's, that's not the case. It's, it's your, you are, your goal right now is to, like, keep all your circulate to ourselves at bay.
You're, everything you do with a knife on a daily basis.
And everything you're doing with it, everything else on a daily basis, your nutrition is to help kill circulate to ourselves.
I'll tell you, I'll put it out there right now. I can't tell you how many people that we find out that they, you know, have passed away.
They're doing this for 25 years now. And we get their right back and they stop using their right seven months ago or a year ago, because they thought they were cured.
And down in their cancer, quote, unquote, came back with the vengeance. And then they were so sick they didn't even start using it again and they passed away.
Remember circulate to ourselves. We'll not show up on a PET scan. Everybody's got them. Everybody's got cancer cells, even if you've never been diagnosed with cancer, keep using your right. Don't stop.
Don't get lazy. Don't think you don't use it anymore. Continue using on a daily basis.
All right, with that, we'll say goodbye and know that I'm praying for you guys all and foot baths to not necessarily, but continue to use your life.